bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat l'énergie nucléaire est
elle vraiment si bon marché c'est la
question que se sont posée cette semaine
les sénateurs de la commission d'
enquête sur le coût réel de
l'électricité
ils ont en effet auditionné les
responsables allemands de l' agence
fédérale de l'électricité il faut dire
qu en france l électricité 25% moins
cher qu'en allemagne tout de suite donc
direction à la salle clémenceau
poursuivre les travaux de cette
commission denquête bonne matinée à tous
je voudrais remercier madame anne grete
gros bol d'avoir accepté de venir
bon qui parle un petit peu français mais
je crois que pour le débat nous avons un
interprète nous avons des écouteurs et
est ce ça va je pense que vous allez
parler en allemand
je voudrais vous remercier beaucoup
d'être d'être venu je crois que vous
avez été informé de cette commission
denquête le sujet que nous très tôt est
un sujet qui est sur lequel il ya une
attente de la part des français parce
qu'il est évident que le coût d'énergie
et le prix d'électricité
il est fonction de notre mix énergétique
et comme en allemagne comme dans
beaucoup d'autres pays européens
ce mix énergétique est en train
d'évoluer compte tenu de la conjoncture
économique ont tenu du problème du
nucléaire à la suite de fukushima compte
tenu d'un certain nombre de certain
nombre de sujets alors pour
pour que nous puissions profiter de
votre expérience et notamment de votre
rôle
auprès du régulateur allemand notre
rapporteur vous adresser au préalable un
certain nombre de questions sur
lesquelles vous avez plus je pense
travailler un petit peu pour que tout
soit bien enregistrer il va se permettre
de rappeler les questions puisque ce
débat est à la fois filmé et enregistré
monsieur le rapporteur très rapidement
les questions la première question
portait madame e revel sur eux
la présentation du marché de
l'électricité en allemagne dans votre
pays
deuxième question est ce que ce prix
actuel de l'électricité de roupies
reflète correctement les coûts réels
d'électricité troisième question quelle
est l'évolution du prix de l'électricité
dans votre pays pour les cinq années à
venir
quatrième question comment devrait
évoluer le mix électrique et notamment
la part des énergies renouvelables
1 et puis vous pouvez pas nous parler du
choix qui a été fait en allemagne de la
politique entre en matière d'électricité
et cinquième question quelle est votre
position sur les réseaux de transport
les smart grid enfin l'ensemble des
réseaux intelligents il ya t'il une
réflexion spécifique en allemagne sur ce
mois voir monsieur le président j'ai
voulu résumer les cinq questions de
telle manière qu'on laisse plus de temps
madame robben merci monsieur le
rapporteur invités j'ai comment sont ils
si peu en français ce que j'aime bien la
langue j'ai fait des études ici à paris
donc c'est un peu un challenge et puis
parce que la situation est ce le marché
en allemagne est bien sûr et puis après
pour pour les questions plus techniques
je l'utilisé la demande moi comme vous
savez je suis ici pour les régulateurs
et le monde qui régule on est honnête
régulateur pour les cinq secteurs pour
l'électricité pour le gas pour la
télécommunication pour la poste et aussi
pour les raisons du drame est ce ça ce
sont les cinq secteurs il ya beaucoup d
énergie là dessus aussi
donc on lemagnen on a déjà fait
l'ouverture du marché à la concurrence
dès 1904 1,98 lors des premières
directif européen c'est la réalisation
du marché intérieur à partir de cette
date
on a aussi commencé on a permis les
consommateurs d'échanger leurs
fournisseurs donc c'était le marché de
taille vous lectrices et l'été et aussi
pour les gars étaient libres et ils que
vous pouvez choisir des qualités c'est
tâtre déjà et il y a une particularité
dans le marché al montrent qu'il faut
bien
sa voix s'est
la première est qu'on a quatre gestion
gestionnaire de réseau d'électricité de
transport c'est bien r w et eux et on
puis vattenfall est aussi et un bébé il
ya pas ça jusqu'à très récemment que
et tf1 ont été on avait une partie d un
bébé et un b w
et puis on a environ 12 gestion de
réseau transport en gas et on a beaucoup
beaucoup des gestionnaires des réseaux
taissy potter donc environ vite sont des
destructions électricité et s'ils sont
pour les gas beaucoup beaucoup
donc ça veut dire et conques l'allemagne
a aussi une distribution des
responsabilités des régulations nous la
règle et le bouddhisme est sagan tout
est responsable pour les touts les
raisons des gestionnaires réseau
transports et aussi pour certaines des
raisons qu'ils ont sur qui ont plus de
100000 raccordés et aussi qu'ils sont
installés sur plus des territoires bien
sûr ça c'est important et pour les
autres ce sont des régulateurs
régionales ou kid en effet
interrégionale ça veut dire pour les
landes à ça c'est la structure qui est
un peu difficile et un peu quelque fois
un peu
compliqué mais qui a aussi des avantages
par exemple pour le benchmarking etc
gervinho sur sur sa donc je vais rentrer
en allemagne et maintenant on annonce
pour pour faire les chiffres et s'être
heures pour le marché amm dit la
production d'électricité augmenté en
2010 pour atteindre 160 gigawatts et
environ 30% pour l'option sont produits
ils à partir des énergies renouvelables
et plus particulièrement à partir de
l'éolien à savoir 27 mégawatts à partir
de l'énergie solaire concours en 2007 ne
pas remonter leurs actions
production réduite falloir tenir nos
engagements français un alcootest de
l'environnement renard dont la sortie en
2006 et jusqu'en 2010 à nous avons
reproduit jay buente un gigawatt à
partir du nucléaire et du gaz
et comme le savent il ya deux ans après
la catastrophe de fukushima le 11 mars
nous avons décidé d'arrêter un certain
nombre de centrales nucléaires et alors
ce que nous avons vu des yeux pour la
nouvelle législation en 2010 cette
décision était définitivement entériné
des 17 centrales nucléaires nous avons
arrêté définitivement neuf centrales
nucléaires nous avons là donc une perte
de production et d'électricité certaines
mais c'est le mental est peut être déjà
compensé en partie par les énergies
renouvelables
cette sortie du nucléaire signifie que
nous devons davantage faire appel à
l'éolien notamment par le biais
d'installations de parc éolien dans la
mer du nord mais dans la mer baltique
ceci demande évidemment des
investissements conséquents l'art
ailleurs il faut restructurer et à
adapter les réseaux de transport
d'électricité pour pouvoir intégrer
injecté
les nouvelles les énergies des énergies
renouvelables en effet la production à
partir d'énergies renouvelables et
davantage décentralisée est beaucoup
plus décentralisée que dans le cas de la
production à partir du nucléaire et du
charbon
il faut donc restructurer les réseaux
par ailleurs en allemagne beaucoup de
centrales nucléaires l'option auto
production industrielle nous faut mener
notamment l'industrie dans le sud et
dans le sud ouest de l'allemagne
beaucoup de sens trahi se trouvaient
dans ces régions du sud et le sud-ouest
de l'allemagne les centrales qui ont été
fermés alors donc la production à pied
owlient nantais se situer
géographiquement surtout au nord de
l'allemagne dans la mer du nord
il faut donc adapter les réseaux de
transport et il faut renforcer notamment
le transport de l'électricité à partir
du nord de l'allemagne vers le sud pour
y être mais par ailleurs comme je l'aï
déjà dit il faut restructurer une raison
pour vouloir davantage intégrer les
énergies renouvelables c'est le défi le
plus important qui se posent à nous en
allemagne après la sortie du nucléaire
on n'y a aucun problème qui en découlent
qui fait que nous avons aussi de
nouvelles missions pour ces deux aspects
les investissements nécessaires dans
l'éolien en mer et les investis qu'est
ce que ça va représenter en termes
d'augmentation de la facture
d'électricité pour les allemands
viens nous ferons ce prêt qui nomadisent
avons procédé à certaines estimations
ont considéré je ne vais pas vous donner
ici des montants absolus
car en ce moment comme en france il ya
des négociations avec les gestionnaires
du réseau des jeunes et que ce sont vos
écrits portent que sur des programmes à
10 ans en allemagne nous avons à présent
tu et à toi scénario est différent des
consultations avec elle et je suis un
être quatre grands voyagistes nerfs de
réseaux tetra et transport les scénarios
se différencie essentiellement au bar ou
d'acheter parce que tous les acteurs des
énergies renouvelables la variable de
ses réseaux et étangs du mix énergétique
en effet le volume des investissements
est très largement et déterminé bien ce
mix énergétique donc par la part des
énergies renouvelables
nous assurons en allemagne une très
forte promotion des énergies
renouvelables pour ce qui est de leur
production et c'est ainsi chaque fois
que nous avons déjà une progression va y
furent nous offrit faut dire non à bâle
fong sai son team orange de 200 images
riches qui implique l'énergie
renouvelable en 2011 seulement 26 pour
moi que tu es
pour moi qui joue ça a payé par le
consommateur et de médecins que bien que
leurs 45 centimes par kilowatt donc la
moyenne d'âge foumban forte au niveau
national le doit qu'à 25 45 casino
parking ouest
mais je vous donnerai des informations
corps d'état lié avons donc une
progression de fruits de 200 et celle de
l'île d'ici 2011 est un an et à part
mais mais aussi sur iphone fera siffler
trail et se protègent sur une
progression des prix de 3 à 5% selon le
scénario choisi donc selon le mix
énergétique et donc augmentation
probable de 3 à 5% et des cours des
années à venir
6 en 2006 m
ces jeux procès une part de 35% de la
distribution voyait d'angle le baril
hier hugues en 2006 et aujourd'hui 20%
donc nous avons pu réunir le prix et
leur distribution
mais étant donné que pendant le même
temps est le prix à la production de
l'énergie a progressé
nous n'avons ou a pas eu de réduction
globale des prix à la consommation
en règle générale agit en allemagne le
consommateur ne peut changer ont aussi
de producteur et de distributeur
d'énergie us une possibilité laquelle
les consommateurs
vous entrez largement mattel nous avons
aussi des consommateurs en allemagne qui
chances de fournisseurs et de
distributeurs
parce que tout simplement il souhaite
favoriser le développement des énergies
renouvelables
nous avons donc une partie de
consommateurs qui prête à payer plus
cher son électricité à partir du moment
où celle ci est essentiellement produite
à partir des renouvelables
nous avons bien sûr de façon générale
une augmentation des prix inquiète de
l'électricité suite à la sortie du
nucléaire alegre se redresse redonner
vielle rapidement aussi des informations
concernent hormones efforts des
différentes régions d'énergie car ceci
est très important pour nous comme la
production à proprement parler de l
électricité entre pour environ un tiers
des prix à la consommation au royaume de
la part de la distribution environ 20%
de vie à bord et nagui l'aï seulement
les énergies renouvelables c'est à dire
l'accès qui financent l injection et de
l'énergie renouvelable aussi au fait je
pense que cela correspond en france c
est se dit et en allemagne
donc c'est un mécanisme comparables nous
appelons que j'ai à savoir sur l énergie
renouvelable c'est donc une taxe est
vise à promouvoir l'utilisation de
l'énergie renouvelable
donc cette tare en forteresse et bien
que le 7 % dans le prix à la
consommation il sait très bien que le 7
% sont appelés à progresser à augmenter
puisque nous voulons promouvoir
l'utilisation des énergies renouvelables
ces énergies renouvelables il devrait
passer de 30% à 80% dans le mix
énergétique en 2025 donc date à la
quelle manière les dernières centrales
nucléaires devraient être fermées en
allemagne
la sortie du nucléaire a été décidé en
2000 ronge et nous avons somme au dos
encore 11 12 années devant nous pour
fermer définitivement voit toutes les
centrales nucléaires pour opérer la
restructuration de la production et de
la distribution de l'énergie ce chrono
comme une tunique noire vernie ce n'est
un dow jones en allemagne au flore nous
avons tous décidé de sortir du nucléaire
et suite d'un climat politique aux
objectifs fixés au niveau européen
concernant la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
26 autres et contre les nations de co2
nous devons en allemagne est limité
encore la part occupée par les centrales
au charbon
nous devons à fermer un certain nombre
de centrales au charbon reçoit
définitivement soit les remplacer par
des centrales au charbon plus moderne
qui émettent moins de co2 tout facile
nous avons décidé de renoncer
photo md pourquoi dans les couches
souterraines du co2 car on considère
entre-temps voyons que le fait de
déposer le co2 la terre il y aura des
conséquences négatives nous n'allons
donc pas dans un avenir proche aux yeux
installez peut-être leur réservoir ou du
co2 qui seraient souterraine entre
encore dans le prix à la transformation
et j'essaie de hausser la taxe à yoff
qui doit être payé à la municipalité et
d'en donner le distributeur doit lui
même payer cette taxe et il s'agit de
six bien que le centre pour cent on peut
aussi la fiscalité en trois pour un
quart dans le prix de l'électricité
c'est donc l'heure où l'accès sur
l'électricité et la smart est la fille
en soi un petit jeu prochaine de la
marque saturn
donc si on additionne les accès qui
doivent être obligé à payer la somme de
subventions et des énergies
renouvelables lors vous constateriez que
sont taxés cette subvention entre pour
50% dans le prix de l'électricité in
frankreich woody cru resteront ce que
j'ai 58 ans comprend la production
et c'est cette partie on peut ou non
être régulé car notre agence et les
compétences des yeux que pour le réseau
pour la sauce mac et la vente en gros
oui vous dites 50% pour la production
s'est en réalité je crois j'ai cru
comprendre 50% pour la production et la
distribution
nous sommes par contre tant au niveau de
france
pourquoi la production mois on y pose en
fait trop la distribution la vente car
nous pensions qu'il s'agit là de marché
doivent être soumis à la concurrence
nous sont soumis à un alien contrôle de
l'office des cartels et les prix et
frais non loyaux ne pense qu'à casser
fixé hier ses billets sont déterminés
par le marché et à notre compétence je
vote encore je les dis donc les taxes
ainsi que la taxe de subventions aux
aguets pour les énergies renouvelables
entrent pour 50 profession est dans le
pré finale à la consommation dos
si on me progressé de façon trop
important sur deux façons quoi y est
injustifiée alors fait l'office des
cartels peut intervenir office de carte
ethernet contrôler pour voir s'il ya but
allait intervenir
non il officia des gares telles que
cette fonction de contrôle des primes de
fonction qui a été renforcé en 2009
prend casse avant la sortie du nucléaire
ce 10ème coupe rase
ceci pour éviter une dérive des prix à
la consommation
il faut se ravir en 2009 la compétence
au niveau de la production et de la
distribution elle n'était pas aussi
importante qu'aujourd'hui mais depuis
2009 l'office des cartels n'a pas
constaté que d'abus ou de dérive des
prix dans son service
fring j'ai dit au préalable un goûter
avec cela des mecs là on note que de
plus en plus de consommateurs étaient
tentés de les changer de marque
fournisseurs et de distributeurs comme
touche tandis qu'albi ksar hirane
biannic dacia
nous avons en tant que régulateur
reading markham et id était un certain
nombre de règles qui régissent je désire
normalise standardiser le changement
donc tant au docteur distributeurs à une
autre photo anne moss nous avions par
exemple définit que si on veut changer
le fournisseur alors il le faut
s'adresser aux nouveaux fournisseurs il
faut lui dire je souhaite changer de
fournisseur et c'est donc le nouveau
fournisseur qui en contact avec l'ancien
fournisseur et lison vient d'humour où
se fera le basculement s'est en même
temps ce n'est donc il veut alors t'es
pas problématique c'est très simple
ailleurs la russie qui sécurise aussi le
consommateur final puis ce conseil le
nouveau fournisseur qui doit convenir
avec l'ancien fournisseur du moment du
basculement du centre à environ 6 et
bien que le simple bon sens des
consommateurs ont utilisé cette
possibilité ni autiste d'asf il convenu
par ailleurs beaucoup de consommateurs
avant mais irmelin change pas forcément
de fournisseurs mais négocient leurs
tarifs avec leurs fournisseurs
c'est donc pas un changement de
fournisseur mais un changement de
contrat pour obtenir des conditions plus
avantageuses
ceci montre que les consommateurs
connaissent leurs droits savent
pertinemment qu'ils peuvent changer de
fournisseur et utilisé cet argument pour
re négocier de meilleurs tarifs avec
leurs fournisseurs actuels
il ya eu aussi un certain nombre de
jurisprudence dans ce domaine
relationnel et mais qui veulent y sommes
prêts les gestionnaires de réseau à toi
fallait présenter aux consommateurs d
ces informations pertinentes en cas
d'augmentation de prix si le
gestionnaire de réseau wan n'est pas en
mesure d'expliquer aux consommateurs des
tenants et les aboutissants d'une
augmentation de bruit le client le
consommateur est en droit de refuser
cette augmentation de prix
le soc ya donc beaucoup renforcer les
droits des consommateurs et j'ai dit au
préalable qu'en lan your own site
us notes le marché avait été libéralisé
de façon informelle depuis 1998 mais
dans la réalité cette ouverture y est
c'est fait de façon est très très lente
en effet les possibilités de changer de
fond d'une firme de fournisseurs étaient
extrêmement à limiter ce n'était pas
prévu par l'office des cartels et ceci a
beaucoup voyagé freiner cette ouverture
des marchés
c'est le législateur a connu cette
situation aux 2005 surtout bini ont
reconnu que la seule présence de
l'officier des cadets les jeunes
n'étaient pas suffisantes pour opérer
cette ouverture est donc le législateur
a adopté en 2005 un nouveau white acquis
en 2005 que j'ai menée quand nous a
confié notre agence cette compétence
supplémentaire qui est la nôtre
maintenant vos mails
même qu'il te que la creux ou nantes en
français cela fait que depuis 2005 nous
avons aussi des compétences est en test
fut pas décisif pour pouvoir procéder à
une meilleure régulation et pour
procéder à les vertus rodez marché
désormais donc nos consommateurs ont la
possibilité de changer de fournisseur
ils utilisent cette possibilité et ceci
et que tu as fait à 100 ailleurs à la
dig your own domicile et nous sépare
ligue 1 2009 nous avons opté pour une
régulation incitatif
c'est à dire nos fictions wire la faune
sauvage et les courriels une ceci ne
concerne que les coûts d'investissement
les couilles opérationnel rapidement sur
dix une déception et lui seul une
rentabilité à surveiller pour les
investissements dans les réseaux et
terminaux la foule sur la base d'un
parking j'utilise en voyeur au niveau
des opérateurs sur gazon puis nos vies
qui seront déterminants
de rentabilité que ce geste leur retour
des sautoirs réaliser car dans une
situation de monopole on a pas
d'incitation à économiser mes yeux se
reproduire ce que nous appelons le goal
de lighting cette situation lui à une
gestion comptable de personnel beaucoup
de salariés oui c'est un droit très
important donc en situation de monopole
tout ceci j'ai tout donné pour le marché
nous avons de mieux comprendre le marché
tout en assistant les entreprises à
investir ya donc eu nos misa sur les
lieux d'une part et d'autre part
incitations aux investissements c'est
pour cela que nous avons à fiction que
surpris eric lafond ont déjà jeté par
une fenêtre la citation si les
gestionnaires c'est vrai que le prix
indicatif
alors ils peuvent garder pour l'europe
la direction de c'est ce que j'avais
décidé en 2009
arrivé au terme de l'année prochaine ou
sur mon arrivée on a vu que la première
période de nomination et électricité
depuis une opa seront a donc deuxième
place à connaître si le jeu que nous
c'est en même temps favoriser
l'efficacité de la rentabilité des
investissements dans ces cas là de
retour sur investissement les décisions
mdi des domaines comme une cage à moteur
est meilleure qu'ailleurs c'est nous et
notre attention de façon globale dit
gêné dans les investissements vont
s'auto financer et à la porte dans sa
patrie de l'amortissement des
investissements nets sur une spéciale au
projet qui est mise en avant par
ailleurs suite à la sortie du nucléaire
décidée dit m si les investissements en
dehors investments me2 régulation les
gestionnaires madoff et moi me sens béni
me qualifier de nouveau à moyens pour
investir dans les mesures d'adaptation
c'est la région comme je l'étais déjà
mûr clé
on ne pose pas de problème en ce qui
concerne les investissements nous voyons
les gestionnaires de réseau de même
investi c'est d'y affronter
nous avons aussi des paiements de
pensions une grille pain investissent
plus seulement dans des indications à
des temps d'aimer qui souhaite procéder
à des investissements joyau naturel donc
suite à la panne on sait combien le prix
plafond pour le réseau votre prix
plafond c'est individuel va bien vu que
ces règles et de façon à fait habituelle
nous avons 800 concessionnaires de
réseaux - de distribution à quatre
grands gestionnaires de réseaux de
transport et chaque fois que je suis sur
la bonne voie le troisième temps à
former un taux d'efficacité
puis à l'aide d'une autre confie le
tarif
le prix moyen est fondé à 0 kg vache à
lait était en devoir de ne lire que le
95 sociale
c'est donc la moyenne fonctions relèvent
tous ces réseaux moyenne d'un drm et
comme je l ai dit
ce matin le toit varié en fusion les
constructeurs comme je les ai déjà dit
nous avons 800 ses actionnaires de
distribution qui gère des réseaux plus
ou moins grande
or robben est du niveau supérieur nous
avons les quatre gestionnaires de
transport donc le premier que j'indique
elle savoir 515 en 2011 et 5 80 2010
2009 6 centimes par kilowatt et par
heure il s'agit donc de la moyenne de
moyenne autres ont déraillé surtout
qu'on soit tous les gestionnaires la
normale
encore une fois un problème pour revenir
à ce sujet il précédemment
nous ne voyons pas de problème au niveau
des investissements de financement nous
pensons que les chronos une production
est disponible un différé avec ses 0,09
par action nous avons un taux de
rentabilité ce qui est assez attractif à
une basse bruche pour les escrocs et
sans problème
producteur d'électricité de gaz mais
nous pensons le problème le plus
important du monde connaît me gontard
one se situe au n avons pas été les deux
sens ramassions d'autorisation à ce jour
en elle même
les la programmation et les
autorisations ont été réalisés au niveau
watts et ellen d'art et non pas au
niveau fédéral ceci peut vous paraître
bizarre car en france vous avez une
organisation est tout à fait différente
beaucoup plus centralisée ce qui est son
niveau là certainement des avantages en
allemagne nous avons donc un système
fédéral mais ils sont que certains
länder et déjà donné leur accord
alors que d'autres sont en retard et
nous avons donc constaté suite à la
sortie du nucléaire soit comme il est
l'heure pour aller changer cette façon
d'organiser la programmation et
l'autorisation accorde maintenant depuis
confier la responsabilité de la
programmation et de l'autorisation et
notre agence par le biais d'une loi
intitulé loi portant sur le
développement du réseau
c'est donc une nouvelle compétence qui
nous a été confiée et qui pis est de
favoriser le développement du réseau et
à dépasser ce pour des problèmes tueur à
la façon décentralisée qui fonctionne
l'allemagne ya plein pense en outre que
des migs pouvoir grâce au changement va
réduire de moitié les délais de
programmation et d'autorisation à passer
de 10 ans à 5 ans ceci devrait nous
permettre de mieux gérer cette
surenchère nucléaire un quart le plus
gros problème qui se pose son équipe à
haïti avec démantèlement sans crainte
développement d'autres capacités de
production le problème qui se creuser au
moins c'est le développement et
l'adaptation à des réseaux aux énergies
non renouvelables etc cette compétence
qui a été confiée à notre agence
c'est cette partie là qui forme
réellement le noyau de notre actif et
est maintenant sur la base du printemps
de dis lisant qui découle également du
troisième programme du marché intérieur
et du camp de développement d'un réseau
badens sur cela il y a également un clan
des besoins fait des roues il va
également être élaborée et ce plan nous
voulons la moue finaliser une avec
thermique 2012 pour que les autres fois
c'est suzuki se faire par la suite et
que les autorisations puis se faire par
doc
ça c'est le concept c'est là dessus que
nous travaillons avec légèreté et il
faut savoir se c'est assez complexe
comme par le passé de la partie ogre
aviation 6 comment dirais je sens un
minimum de coordination est ce qu'il
faut savoir en allemagne il ya une
discussion qui courent comme quoi le
changement lucapa énergétique et
certaines industries porté également par
une grande majorité a plus grande
majorité de la population mais peut
également beaucoup de scientifiques
disent également que de ce fait il ya
plutôt un recul ce qui se fait de
manière à ce que maintenant on ne peut
plus le marché qui a été mise en place à
travers la libéralisation et qu'on se
dirige vers une économie planifiée et ça
c'est une tringle que nous avons
également le président de l'office des
cartels vient également de thématiser
c'est pour cette raison que nous
essayons de faire en sorte les étapes
qui sont nécessaires pour accentuer
accélérer l'extension du réseau soit
réduit au minimum
mais ça veut dire que s'il doit y avoir
plus de planification c'est quelque
chose qui est absolument indispensable
je ne sais pas combien des questions que
vous avez mentionné au cabba combien de
questions j'ai déjà répondu peut-être
vous voulez encore posé vous même des
questions concrètes pour savoir où on en
est merci beaucoup
là là là c'était très bien plus de ce
groupe nous avons bien compris le rôle
du régulateur qu'un rôle très important
sur des problèmes de transport et
beaucoup moins sur les problèmes de
production et de distribution de jeux
tiendra paix parce que je crois qu'il
faut que les questions se concentre sur
les problèmes de transport monsieur va
porter sur le questionnaire et n'ont
donc madame a répondu sur l'ensemble
puisqu'elle a dit que le problème
n'était pas la production et que y'avait
adaptation du réseau
est-ce que j'ai besoin pour faire un
parallèle avec notre situation en france
c'est quand vous parlez du réseau agréé
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous le
réseau est ce que c'est le réseau haute
tension
c'est à dire que le réseau de transport
non c'est aussi la distribution
non non non non la système allemand est
totalement comme le système français le
transport
sauf que ce n'est pas un transporteur il
ya quatre ans en allemagne
c'est notre réseau de transport et les
réseaux de distribution c'est comme erdf
chez nous d'accord pour bien comprendre
sa fille mercy près d'arras - vous allez
peut-être même me répondre avec l'aide
de madame robl c'est les 5 75 centimes
le kilowattheure ça correspond à quel
réseau pour vous président et madame
bobage c'est le réseau haute tension où
le réseau de distribution des sacs 75
douche c'est une moyenne
concernant tous en fête le transport est
également le niveau du réseau de
distribution
et puis également un mécanisme de
basculement oui c'est ce qu'on a fait de
ce mécanisme de basculement ça veut dire
qu'un certain partie des coûts où je
reformule différemment le coup arrive au
niveau du transport et après arrive au
niveau de la distribution
s'il n'y a pas de régie municipale
directe à ce moment là le courant est
transporté via le réseau de transport et
via le réseau distribution arrive au
client final c'est l'utilisation et du
réseau de transport en fait au prorata
également et on en tient compte au
niveau du réseau de distribution pour qu
on n'a plus de palais coup à deux fois
ces 5 2 75 centimes c'est une moyenne de
tous les flics se répercute dans les 20%
justement du coût final consommateurs je
souhaiterais vous poser une question sur
le droit de refus concernant
l'augmentation des tailles j'ai bien
compris que finalement l'ouverture du
marché marche que relativement bien
puisque vous nous avez expliqué que car
un cas c'était à peu près 6 % de gens
qui de clients qui changeait de
fournisseurs en fait nous savons très
bien que chaque grand fournisseur reste
un petit peu en situation mon dos paul
dans sa zone d'influencé et dans les
landes sur lesquels il intervient donc
c'est très difficile
pour un client d'aller se fournir
ailleurs
par contre vous avez bien expliqué que
ce qui marchait mieux c'est la
renégociation du contrat avec son
fournisseur le droit du refus m'a
toujours intrigué je sais que ça existe
mais si un fournisseur globalement ne va
pas augmenter le prix de l'électricité
pour un client que ce soit un
particulier un industriel
c'est pour toutes sa zone d'influencé et
si un fournisseur augmentent les prix
d'électricité
c'est parce qu'il a des besoins
d'investissements c'est parce que
notamment que vous avez évoqué c'est
parce que progressivement il ferme ses
centrales
un gala charbon sale pour les remplacer
par des centrales à charbon plus propre
ou pour remplacer par des centrales à
gaz ou pour remplacer par de l'éolien
autrement dit c'est parce que il ya des
coûts de production et d'exploitation
qui augmente on en demande pour tout le
monde
si un client veut exercer son droit de
refus et s'il obtient gain de cause
c'est à dire que pour lui le tarifs
n'augmentent pas c'est très mauvais pour
le fournisseur parce que tous les autres
clients risquent d'adopter la même
attitude
comment ça fonctionne votre droit du
refus jusqu'à les la marge de manoeuvre
jusqu'où ça peut aller
je pense que ça fonctionne de la manière
suivante nous calculons les coûts totaux
c'est à dire ce n'est que plus tard
qu'on les répercutent sur le
kilowattheure et lorsque nous calculions
qu'est ce que nous faisons nous pouvons
les coûts d'investissement nous prenons
les coûts d'exploitation et ont fait un
total et de gestionnaires de réseau est
également l'institution qui également
fixe de prix avec l'abonnement prix
kilowattheure entre dans une formule
tout cela déterminé par le gestionnaire
de réseau et qui connaît également la
part de clients industriels
le qui au préalable avait une certaine
puissance de négociation et ce qui
faisait que les prix ou leur s'ils
étaient plus à bas comprend donc une
négocier des prix les prix plus bas
ce qui fait que lui même doit intégrer
dans son cri qu'il va perdre des clients
c'est toujours un certain risque
un momentum de risque pour le
gestionnaire de réseau
il faut plus penser c'est à chaque fois
il y a toujours incertain beaucoup et
que c'est quelque chose que le
gestionnaire de réseau doit récupérer à
100%
d'abord il doit calculer le gestionnaire
des réseaux comme quoi il va perdre des
clients
cela il a donc déjà intégrée en amont
dans son prix et lorsqu'ils voient que
il finalement y perd plus de clients qui
n'avaient calculé au préalable à ce
moment là iny lui reste ses
gestionnaires de réseau que de se
focaliser sur les filles c'est à dire
les investissements il ya différentes
catégories de coûts mais nous disons de
principe qui également que les coûts de
capitaux sont contre l'asthme et cela
est très important
nous disons également qu'il faut
également que tu arrives à gérer tes
coups il ne faut pas seulement que tu
peux augmenter tes fringues et quand les
cours remontent tu peut basculer sa sur
les autres sur le client c'est à dire il
faut à ce qu'on en tant que gestionnaire
tu doit influencer les coûts situe le
gestionnaire perd ses clients voilà la
logique sous jacente en dernière
conséquent si tout le monde fait la même
chose forcément oui sort est confronté à
un problème
alors un autre un avantage je pense
qu'en fin de compte ça s'équilibre et
dans le prochain round alors il devrait
à ce moment là pour céder à nouveau
quelques jeunes bien une chose il faut
qu'il faut dire clairement nous avons
différents gestionnaires de réseaux qui
se sont regroupés qui se sont fédérés
parce qu'ils peuvent dire que oui bon
800 gestionnaires de réseau ce n'est pas
efficace du point de vue économique
même s'ils produisent de manière
efficace et rentable
ils sont quand même en dessous du tour
de ski est viable économiquement
et ça c'est également un effet donc la
consolidation a lieu qu'il y à des
regroupements entre gestionnaires de
réseaux qui ont eu lieu parce que de
toute façon plusieurs raisons toujours
des avantages de coût et en fait si on
se regroupe on arrive à produire ses
avantages en termes de pneus et ça ça
est présenté ce type de régulation a eu
lieu et cela inclut également le fait
qu'il y ait des gestionnaires de réseaux
qui quittent le marché ou qui fusionne
entre cette régulation incitative repose
sur le concept comme quoi les coudes
surtout les coûts inefficace nous on a
fait un allin ce mois soit supprimé cela
intègre également cela s'intègre et
lorsqu'il ya une mauvaise un mauvais
investissement a été fait le
gestionnaire de réseau ne peut pas
impérativement s'attendre à ce qu'il va
récupérer ses coûts ça c'est le point
crucial 1
ce peut finalement ben il sera confronté
à ses coûts parce qu'il a été inefficace
il a mal géré comme c'est le cas pour
certaines entreprises également nous
avons beaucoup de réserves ça j'aimerais
le dire également
on a trop de réserves ça c'est mon
opinion d'économistes parce que
justement ce risque a été constaté il y
a beaucoup de réserves mais on ne peut
pas exclure
et il y avait également le cas d'un
gestionnaire de réseau qui s'est
complètement retirée du marché à
fusionner avec un autre pas avoir une
taille économique plus rentables et ça
c'était un effet escompté
c'est que du point de vue de la gestion
on arrive à des tailles minimum plus
intéressant parce que les justes en
gestionnaire que nous avons en allemagne
cela également pour des raisons
historiques qui existent chaque commune
chaque ville avait son réseau avait sa
régie municipale et du point de vue de
la gestion économique s'était pas à
chaque fois efficace et pour nous c'est
quelque chose que nous avons fait
consciemment
c'est à dire que ce secteur des réseaux
en raison de la régulation incitative au
total a été rendu plus efficace et les
gestionnaires de réseaux vous dire autre
chose
après tu appelles gestionnaire de réseau
sur le distributeur lowinger accordé
mire et cherche
mais les personnes des réseaux de
transport les quatre mâts sont appelés
eux voulaient pas laisser les quatre
grands transporteurs c'était lui a cité
tout à l'heure non pas le nom mais
comment vous les appelez pas ce que ces
transporteurs irait chercher
merci plusieurs questions
la première question vous avez dit que
5,75 est une moyenne est ce que vous
pouvez nous donner les écarts de prix
ensuite est-ce que ces écarts de tarifs
sont différents bien sûr j'ai compris
selon les gestionnaires mais aussi
est-ce que ils sont un peu fonction des
länder et vous avez expliqué que comme
on va abandonner le nucléaire et se
mettre sur l'éolien il va falloir
complètement restructuré le réseau ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya des régions qui
vont se trouver plus éloignés maintenant
des centres de production et est ce que
vous constatez que dans des régions
éloignées le tarif est augmentée par et
donc on arriverait à une disparité
géographique du tarif
ma question
si j'ai bien compris il y aura des
investissements faits par des
gestionnaires de réseaux différents ce
qui veut dire que la propriété des
réseaux appartient d des gestionnaires
différents est ce qu'il y a des
difficultés ensuite pour utiliser le
réseau d'un concurrent et comment vous
régler cette question est ce que votre
autorité le suffit ou est-ce qu'à terme
on peut imaginer qu'il y aura des
conflits entre ses gestionnaires pour
quelque part gêner la concurrence
d'arriver sur un réseau qui n'est pas le
sien et ma dernière question mais ça
c'est parce que je ne connais pas quelle
est la part de l'électricité dans le
chauffage en allemagne
concernant la première question je peux
vous présenter en fait l'éventail c'est
entre 3 et 12 centimes mais ça je vais
encore envoyé quelque chose au
secrétariat pour donner les chiffres
exacts parce que je dois vérifier cela 7
ce delta où cet éventail je peux vous le
donnez plus tard qui jusqu'à présent il
n'est pas encore il s'est avéré qu'au
niveau régional ou qu'on a une plus
grande plus en décalage au niveau
régional mais ce n'est pas non plus
quelque chose à exclure le niveau de la
rémunération dépend en fin de compte la
taille également dû raison qu'on médias
de clients qui sont par exemple à
raccorder au réseau les coûts
d'enfouissement par exemple de tranchées
qui doivent être offerts et ça dépend si
vous trouvez en ville si vous êtes à la
campagne c'est au nord où le pays est
assez plat ou si vous trouvez plutôt
dans le sud de l'allemagne où devait
passer à travers au creuset à travers
les alpes enfin jambes ça dépend
vraiment c'est très différenciée il ya
des particularités régionales dont il
faut tenir compte
et lorsqu'un homme est très homogène
à ce moment là c'est pas toujours le cas
en allemagne à ce qu'on a on arrive à
couvrir les coûts on ne serait-ce
golstein au nord c'est à dire pas de la
mer du nord
il faut savoir que le pays est en
général plus plat que en bavière
dans le sud avec ses mots et qu'elle ne
support est par exemple également dans
le schleswig-holstein il peut y avoir
également des régions où le pouls des
sons plus élevé que par exemple en
bavière à munich à mini qui peut être
assez abordable parce que vous avez
également une forte densité que de
creuser c'est à dire les coûts des
réseaux dépendent également de la
densité également de la longueur et de
combien de câbles vous pouvez avoir dans
une tranchée c'est le cas également dans
les nouveaux réseaux de
télécommunications d'après notre
règlement il faut que l'on tienne compte
d'un grand nombre de paramètres qui
puisse influencer directement les coûts
ce qui veut dire que ça varie en
fonction ou le plus grands paramètres
qui influencent cela ce sont les
particularités géologiques géographique
si c'est homogène à ce moment là les
rémunérations de réseau et des
transports sont également homogène
voilà ça c'était la première réponse
deuxième réponse et l'accès au réseau et
là c'est un accès au réseau réglementé a
comme par le passé donc négocier ou le
problème que vous avez dit pouvait
arriver c'était jusqu'en 2005 où les
gestionnaires avaient négocié ceux là
ont également négocié de prix et en fin
de compte c'était pas vraiment
il ya bhl économiquement c'est pour
cette raison qu'on a mise en place cette
procédure etc sant qui est également
prévue dans les directives
cela veut dire que nous on peut obliger
à ce qu'il y ait un accès aux réseaux
qu'ils soient donnés dans la loi il est
dit et je pense que dans la loi
française il est stipulé la même chose
comme quoi il ya un droit à l'accès au
réseau ou l inverse c'est quelqu'un qui
a un réseau doit accorder un accès à son
réseau de principe tous ces impératifs
qui la seule chose qui dont il s'agit ce
sont les rémunérations mais là nous
avons également voix au chapitre si
quelqu'un refuse l'accès au réseau
l'autre peut s'en plaindre
et nous avons à ce moment là la
compétence d'imposer donc ses accès au
réseau
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
déterminant et ça c'est une grande
différence par rapport à avant où il y
avait que seulement l'accès au réseau
négocié en fait la régulation en
allemagne a commencé en 2005 depuis ce
moment-là d'accès au réseau et
réglementée et nous avons accepté une
régulation de la rémunération des
réseaux qui sont concentrées sur
l'efficacité voilà le coin est
déterminant ce qu'on peut donc vraiment
obligé à ce qu'on accorde des conflits
mais à ce moment là nous sommes
l'autorité qui ont ils doivent résoudre
ce problème
j'ai oublié par contrat de troisième
question pas d'anges m'en excuse vous en
aviez encore une troisième de questions
je veux avant vous dirai ce que rapport
à votre réponse est ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'il faudrait aller vers une
péréquation du tarif de façon à ne pas
infliger une double peine aux régions
les plus montagnarde et les plus et les
moins denses est ce que c'est en
discussion en allemagne car l'écart de
prix est extraordinaire la dernière
question était quelle est la part de
l'électricité dans le chauffage en
allemagne
non à une grossesse lily nous fixons les
rémunérations sur la base des coûts et
lorsque les coûts sont différentes
à ce moment là ça se reflète également
dans les rémunérations que nous
accordons des tarifs que nous avons et
nous voulons justement nous ne voulons
pas d'un tarif uniforme au niveau de
l'électricité s'était jamais non plus
une revendication comme toi nous avions
à chaque fois 800 différents réseaux ce
qui est surprenant
al'inverse 215 contacter notre secteur
de la télécommunication où il ya un
grand gestionnaire opérateurs où il y
avait fixé par l'état un seul tarif
homogène et on s'attendait aussi qu'il y
ait seulement un tarif objet ne s'était
jamais le cas dans l'électricité parce
qu'il ya toujours eu les fournisseurs
locaux et chacun savait que les prix
étaient différents et c'est pour cette
raison que pour le secteur de
l'électricité et c'est intéressant ici
en allemagne
cette discussion n'a pas lieu d'être il
ya également une règle qui chapeaute les
autres qui découle directement de la
constitution faut savoir que la loire
c'est au fondamental à landi en 7
il faut vérifier à ce que les comptes on
est arrivé à ce que les conditions de
vie soit homogène
les cous soit une chaîne mais dans le
secteur de l'électricité à linverse de
ses clients de la télécommunication
ça n'a jamais abouti je pense que les
gens sont tout simplement habitués comme
quoi
gestionnaire local ou un fournisseur
local c'est pour eux c'était quelque
chose qui est un petit directement au
coût de la vie traditionnelle pour eux
ça ne les dérange les hommes d'acheter
les organes étaient sociaux ça ne mène
pas sur une industrie vers une
discussion la main concernant ces
différences
bon on discute certes lorsque les faits
cités augmente mais on ne discute pas
des différences de prix en allemagne
et puis également une réponse que nous
connaissons du secteur des
télécommunications
c'est que en principe c'est vrai si on a
un prix uniforme ça ne tient pas compte
des coûts chasse qu'un coup unique ne
peut pas réfléchir les différences de
coûts non plus c'est pas possible
est ce que l'économiste dit toujours
dans la ville je paye également plus de
loyer est également je suis plus près
j'ai également d'autres avantages
et si l inverse j'habite en rase
campagne
et lorsque j'ai les avantages d'un loyer
plus faibles ou lorsque j'ai par exemple
ma propre maison parce que j'habite à la
campagne
à ce moment là j'ai peut-être des coûts
de transport plus élevés et saas est en
fait la normalité c'est ça c'est comme
ça que se répercute des préférences
différentes
je ne peux pas vous donner la quote-part
mais je vais regarder de plus près mais
ce que je peux vous dire ce qu'il est
nettement plus faible qu'en france en
allemagne pour la partie de chauffage
électrique on ne chauffe beaucoup moins
avec les festivités que c'est le cas en
france mais le zou donnerait les
chiffres exacts
cependant le mal je connais quoi sion
que tu des particularités aux jeunes
était française n'existe pas de
réoccuper d'exister quasiment nul en
europe jean-claude vous a dit que pour
la suite de la sortie unique l'air vous
serez amenés donc à restructurer le
réseau transport empathie geek comme
pendant que beaucoup d'écrits jt qui
venaient du sud maintenant du nord
ils rejettent également les sources
d'énergie alors je me dis que ça opposé
est-ce que six lignes de transport ouest
construite à l'aérien ou un souterrain
et si elles sont construites à érié
est-ce que vous avez vous aurez vous a
eu des difficultés à les implanter à les
construire en allemagne et ça se discute
de formule 1 à ce jour la loft var on a
induit évidemment white et coûts
supérieurs 6 fois supérieure et ses
coûts ce sur comme toi et puis amant
aussi être intégrés grotte moins deux
éléments de fait la scission à faire
marcher sur la question notamment moi
parce que nous aurons à faire face à un
surcroît de couvrir pour l'énergie et 30
la société nucléaire le fait dans ses
meilleurs les câbles évidemment voir en
force
entre temps on a également constaté que
l'enfouissement niche homelink homme aux
mille francs un cliché c'est pas
forcément plus écologique ne vaut en
suisse et un câble de 380 cas kilowatts
alors plus rien ne pousse
car ce câble se dégage une tension de
chaleur
nos fans comme pandaria flight training
and times cette constatation
évidemment il ya à considérer le
problème et ont commencé à se dire que
le fait d'utiliser un transport aérien
serait non seulement plus économique
mais peut-être aussi plus écologique
on a souvent prétendu que le transport
aérien n'était pas écologique
je ne sais pas ce qui justifie cette
constatation nous n'avons aucune étude
scientifique qui met en évidence que le
transport aérien de l'électricité au
pèsent sur l'environnement
je me rappelle aussi toute la discussion
qui a eu lieu au conseil général les
émetteurs des téléphones mobiles
kyle busch dînette journées courtes en
grèce de toute façon il veille sur est
donc l'adaptation est d arriver jusqu à
ce que cela pèsera aussi sur le choix du
transport ou pas fournir de
l'électricité d'offres votre deuxième
question actuellement neurones mitch des
burgondes marron organisons des réunions
avec les citoyens pour leur expliquer
les mesures et l'évolution à venir
j'ai dit au préalable qu'il existe une
très large majorité dans la population
qui s'est prononcé en faveur de la
sortie du nucléaire
mais lorsque évidemment voyons les
styles ailleurs une ligne de haute
tension à proximité
le certains villages sont aussi je suis
si deux des réactions tout le monde dira
si on veut bien mais pas chez moi et
c'est précisément pour essayer de
convaincre ses citoyens que nous
organisons ce type de rencontre et nous
leur faisons valoir qu'il faut faire des
choix on ne peut pas en même temps
renoncer au nucléaire va et renoncer
yoro installation à c'est comme
lorsqu'on s'agit a ajouté que pour une
formation à l'aéroport il faut toujours
peser le pour et le contre mais nous
espérons par le travail d'information je
veux voir convaincre de nos citoyens
facebook afin qu'ils acceptent cet
agrandissement d'horizon très souvent
des projets de partir le passé ou être
contrecarrée par tous les citoyens ont
protesté contre des projets c'est pour
cela que nous essayons moi vraiment très
en amont maintenant d'informer les
citoyens de leur expliquer la situation
de comptes de montreuil qu'elle pourrait
être libre de son futur et surtout
russie a été intégré leurs propositions
parce que parfois il ya des citoyens ne
disent pas il suffit de déplacer les
poteaux de 5 mètres à droite ou à gauche
pour éviter un certain nombre yeux de
conséquences négatives 2 essayons donc
de mettre l'accent sur ce processus
social interactif participatif nous
essayons de tenir compte aussi des
propositions ni les sites et citoyens
bon ma poubelle vraiment je remercie
beaucoup
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sur le coût réel de
l'électricité pour revoir cette audition
notre site internet publicsenat.fr très
belle journée à tous